Let's go back to the main
activity of our Just Java app.
Specifically we were looking at
the display message method and
trying to figure out everything
that was going on in here.
Even though the findViewById method is
not declared within this class we know
now that it's actually defined in the
super class in the AppCompatActivity.
Same for setContentView.
This is defined within
the AppCompatActivity class.
But what exactly is happening
in this method, and
why do we need to pass in a resource ID?
Why do we have extra parentheses here?
To answer that question, I'm going to
summarize everything we've learned so
far and
lead you to why this code exists here.
Do you remember this diagram?
When you click on the app icon on the
device it opens up the main activity.
Within our code the onCreate method
of the main activity gets called by
the system.
Within this method we have
a method called to setContentView
with the resource layout ID.
In an earlier exercise we passed in
a single text view for set content view.
But we want more than one view for
our app.
So we pass in a layout resource ID.
This maps to an XML file.
Once we set the content view,
the activity goes and
finds the XML layout file and
then reads through each line.
For each view, it inflates, or
creates, a Java object for it.
It goes through the XML file, and
then builds up this whole
hierarchy of Java objects.
When it's inflating each of these views,
it's actually calling the constructor,
NewTextView or NewLinearLayout, and then
it's passing in all these attributes
into the Java object, so
that it can be set up properly.
Notice that we didn't have to write code
for NewTextView or NewLinearLayout, and
to set the font size.
All of it was handled by the inflation
process of the activity.
To interact with these views while the
app is running and to change them, for
example, to change the text or
to change the buttons,
then we need to find these Java objects.
Once we find them, we can store them
as variables in the main activity.
Remember, we're not creating
new TextViews from scratch,
we're just finding the existing
ones in this view hierarchy.
These are the variables we've used so
far in the main activity.
We have a variable for quantity,
price, and price message.
This is a mix of local and
global variables.
To interact with the views in the view
hierarchy we should create variables
that reference these specific views.
For example, we can create a variable
called quantity text view,
that would refer to this TextView here.
If you click on the plus or
minus buttons in the UI,
then you can change the TextView
text to show a different number.
We can also have a variable
called orderSummaryTextView
that points to this TextView.
When you click on the order button
then the orderSummaryTextView
will change its text to
show the new order summary.
So you can see how having variables
that point to some of these views would
be useful for
changing the UI when the app is running.
But how do we make the connection
between this variable here
to this TextView?
And how do we make the connection
between orderSummaryTextView, here, and
this TextView?
Back in the layout XML file,
remember that we assigned
view IDs to certain views?
For this TextView, we gave it
a view ID of quantity.text.view.
For this view we gave it an ID
order.summary.text.view.
It's optional to assign IDs to views and
you only should assign a view ID if
you need to refer to that view later.
For example you can assign view IDs to
everything, but that's unnecessary.
We only really need to refer to these
two views later in our Java code.
So let's just assign
IDs to these two views.
Okay, we've established
that views have view IDs so
that we can refer to them
later in the Java code.
We also established that we want
variables that point to these views so
that we can manipulate these views.
But we still don't exactly know
how to make the connection between
this variable and
this specific Java object.
And same for this variable and
this Java object.
In the AppCompatActivity class,
I want to show you a specific method.
It's called findViewById and
it takes as input a resource ID.
The findViewById method
finds a view that corresponds with
the ID that is passed as an input.
And the activity searches for this view
in the view hierarchy from the XML that
was processed in the onCreate method.
So like I was mentioning earlier,
the activity onCreate method
sets up a view hierarchy and
then the findViewByID method goes and
finds a view within that view hierarchy.
The return value of this method
is an object of type view.
This left hand column shows the return
value for all of these methods.
This means that within our activity
code we can call findViewById,
pass in the resource ID of the view
that we want, and then it will return
a view object and then we can store
that as a variable within the activity.
The MainActivity Java code
would look like this.
We can call findViewById and
then pass in as an input the resource
ID of the view that we want.
We gave this TextView an ID
of order.summary.text.view.
So here we reference it as
R.id.order_summary_text_view.
This method will go and traverse the
whole view hierarchy and then look for
the view with this ID.
Then it will return this Java object
as a return value of this method.
We can store the return value into
this variable on the left-hand side,
called orderSummaryTextView, and
this is a variable of type View.
So, this returns a view and
we store it inside a view variable.
Later in the MainActivity, we can also
call findViewById and then pass in this
resource ID, R.id.quantity_text_view,
which refers to this TextView here.
This is the TextView in
the quantity picker.
When this is called the activity will
search through the view hierarchy and
then try to find the view with this ID.
Then it will return this view and
then we can store that in a variable
called quantity_text_view.
This variable also has
a data type of View.
This explains how you can
have quantityTextView and
orderSummaryTextView variables
within the MainActivity and that
these variables can connect to these
Java objects in the view hierarchy.
By the way,
I listed the data types here of each of
these variables in the left-hand column.
So these two variables have
a type View as declared here.